it's great to welcome back to the
program today David Faris who's an
associate professor of political science
at Roosevelt University also author of
it's time to fight dirty how Democrats
can build a lasting majority in American
politics great to have you back on David
first of all great to be honest thanks
for having me so last time you were on
we talked about some of the things that
Democrats could do that you feel would
improve their electoral chances we
talked about areas in which Democrats
have historically or at least recently
not performed particularly well in terms
of campaign and political strategy what
are what are you starting to see now as
the 2020 primary gets going and we have
a number of candidates many with
different approaches and political views
is anyone in particular doing something
right or wrong and bigger picture how is
this Democratic primary shake shaping up
at a sort of higher level sure so I've
been really happy to see so several of
the candidates talking about procedural
reform so you have you know people like
Elizabeth Warren and through digit
talking about eliminating the filibuster
which is that's like the gateway drug
so for Democrats to be able to do
anything if they get back into power
because there's all there's no way that
we're getting to 60 seats for 2020 I'd
say there is no way right so if we sit
around waiting for you know seven or
eight Republican votes for for the
things that we want to do whether that's
Medicare for all or whether that's
comprehensive immigration reform we're
gonna be very disappointed then we're
going to waste our time in office so if
the filibuster stuff is is quickly
becoming almost a kind of a litmus test
in the Democratic primary to feel and
I'm really happy to see that let's talk
about that briefly because as much as I
agree with you about the importance of
it strategically empirically in terms of
passing legislation is that a voting
issue like is the is that going to be a
voting issue both within the primary and
in the general election I don't think in
the general election no but I think in
the primary I think that there are a
large group of committed activists who
want to hear our candidates at least say
that the
willing to entertain the idea of doing
away with the filibuster you know like I
don't think they had to go out and say
like I'm gonna do this on day one but I
think he saw like Cory Booker who went
on pod save America said you know I
really like to get cooperation from
Republicans and he had to walk that back
and so it looks to me like there is a a
slice of the primary electorate that
wants to hear how our candidates will
address the structural issues in the
Senate and the best way to do that is to
eliminate the filibuster and have get a
simple majority rule like they do you
want every other legislature on earth
okay fair point III would still assert
that a lot of the even Democratic
primary voting public doesn't really
know much about Senate procedure for
better or worse than that that's sort of
borne out by the polling so now moving
on to what we might agree as more
preeminent voting issues how do you
think the conversation is shaping up in
the primary I you know I think that all
of the candidates are on board with with
the reform that was passed out of the
house that's a HR one and that does
things like you know restore the Voting
Rights of ex-felons it does things like
expand automatic voter registration it
has a procedure I don't think it goes
far enough but it has a procedure to
address voter ID laws in the way that
they have a tendency to suppress
Democratic votes so in terms of voting
rights I think basically everyone in the
primary field is on board with what the
house wants to do you know I obviously
like to see them go a couple of little
bit further with a couple of those
things but I think it's a I think it's a
reasonable starting point to open that
conversation and I think that the
there's real momentum building for
things like DC and Puerto Rico statehood
which would also really help the balance
of power in the Senate and I expect that
to become sort of more like the
filibuster in the sense that it's uh it
becomes a litmus test for our candidates
in the primary and the sort of the most
active and engaged voters in the
Democratic primary will want to hear
that that our candidates are on board
with those kinds of things so sticking
with 2020 but now starting to shift the
Democrats in the house and what might be
available to them now that they have
been sworn in as a majority in the house
the Muller report news which of course
is my audience knows is the bar summary
of the molar summary of the molar
investigation which is what we have so
far how if at all should this be
discussed by the 2020
candidates and and who's doing it right
who's doing it wrong if anybody so far
you know what I hear from the candidates
really generally is you know what I
think makes sense which is that we have
not seen the mullet report and we're
gonna wait to make any judgments about
about actions based on the report until
we've seen it you know and so right now
I think what they're doing is they're
trying to put pressure on the Attorney
General to make sure that he releases a
report that has few rejections as
possible and doesn't make any effort to
cover up the president's wrongdoing you
know I think that the voters in general
are not as engaged with this issue as
those of us who have been thinking about
it for two years might be yeah I think
the polar I think the polling bears out
but the contention that the whole Trump
Russia scandal is not it doesn't make a
top-five list or maybe even a top 10
list of the voters concerns and so I'd
be reluctant to see our primary
candidates pushing the Russia scandal
too heavily but that's not to say that I
don't think our elected officials in
Congress should not be doing everything
that they can in terms of their
oversight powers to bring anywhere I'm
doing too light to follow up with
hearings and to really keep the heat on
the president as much as possible
because as much as voters may not see
this as a top-tier issue the flip side
of that is that actually gives Democrats
in Congress a lot of wriggle room to to
be aggressive with the scandal and to be
aggressive with the president personal
dealings and business dealings prior to
and after he took office as president
yeah I mean my my approach from a while
ago and I spent a lovely part of last
week of pulling old clips just to rika
Munich eight to my audience that my
position has been it's it's the chances
of
Trump personally being caught criminally
conspiring to collude as an individual
were always almost zero there were
questions as to what specifically would
be proven but that either way it's not a
campaign platform to run on impeachment
to run on anything related to the
investigation to run on removal under
the 25th amendment and that's where my
concern is now growing that there is not
beyond the fact that yes Bernie Sanders
has mainstreamed a lot of ideas that in
2016 who were more rare within the
Democratic Party that's a really good
thing and I like to see that I'm worried
that there is not sort of like a robust
new platform that has changed
drastically from what Bernie was talking
about in 2016 which yes more can that
it's now or behind do you disagree I
mean is there what would you point to as
the pillars of the 2020 sort of
discussion that's taking place now well
I didn't I think you know you saw the
president this week sort of endorsed yet
again repealing the entirety of the
Affordable Care Act right which is just
mind-boggling to me because I think that
that position the Republican position on
health care costs Republicans the Senate
I mean to the house and so I think the
health care is gonna be from Senator in
2020 and I think there's a lot of space
for the different candidates to hash out
exactly what their position is on
expanding access to health care and
reducing costs I think you'll see a
split pretty clear split between
candidates endorsing Medicare for all or
some personal Medicare for all and then
candidates who might take a more
centrist approach and that will play out
as the primary unfolds beyond that I
would like to see some more policy
innovation or at least some more some
Siddhant policy discussions taking place
tonight
I do think that'll happen on the debates
start and the candidates start fleshing
out you know where they stand on various
things I think Democrats really need an
immigration plan like a positive
immigration plan but you know we've
spent several years you know criticizing
the president's policies here and then
developing party's policies but what do
we stand for right beyond we don't want
kids in cages and beyond you know we
want to slow the pace of deportations
and maybe reform is our
so what is the plan for sort of taking
this issue off the table moving forward
you know like how do we do right by all
of the undocumented immigrants who are
here
what is the system that we want to put
into place and how do we communicate
that to voters because the president as
we know I think is gonna run an
immigration there's there's no question
in my mind in my mind and while I don't
think that worked for him in the
midterms in the house we can't sort of
discount the possibility that it could
be a powerful issue for him in his base
moving into 2020 and I think Democrats
need to have more than opposition to the
president's position on immigration I
think we need concrete plans for that so
last time you were on we talked about
packing the courts you've mentioned DC
and Puerto Rican statehood there's these
ideas about splitting up California in a
way that would be potentially
advantageous to Democrats let's talk
just about the period between now and
when the next Congress is sworn in in
January of 2021 what do you want to see
Democrats do now that they can actually
do that would not just be these sort of
symbolic moves well you know there's
have a very limited power to enact any
legislation things related to the
Supreme Court or things related to DC
and Puerto Rico stated I do think that
they really should pass statehood bills
440c and Puerto Rico in this Congress in
other words you know debate them pass
them out of the house we know that they
will die on Mitch McConnell's desk but I
think that there's still real value in
demonstrating to the voters what what a
Democratic Congress would look like and
the kinds of laws that a Democratic
president would sign if we have a
Democratic Congress and a Democratic
president you know sometimes sometimes
my audience says what's the point in
wasting time with these symbolic votes
that aren't going to pass they look at
the 60 something votes that Republican
did Republicans did on repealing the
Affordable Care Act when obviously that
wasn't going to get through at most you
know President Obama obviously would
have vetoed it if it could even get
through the Senate you're saying one of
the benefits of doing that is you're
signaling that if you vote a particular
way in the Senate and for the presidency
next time
this is the type of stuff that could
actually pass they're not just talking
about it they're actually doing it in
the house exactly yeah and I don't mean
pass it 30 times every time you know
McConnell doesn't touch it I think that
you pass each of those bills once and
then you run out in the same way that
they're doing with with HR 1 so with the
you know with the voting reform bill
it's also got anti-corruption elements
and stuff about lobbying you know
obviously that's not gonna become law
before 2021 we know that Mitch McConnell
immediately sabotage the whole thing and
I walked out there and said you know I'm
not gonna bring it to the floor because
I don't have to and that's probably what
he's gonna do with all legislation
related to these Democratic priorities
but that doesn't mean that that HR 1 did
not have real value because we are now
talking about things like a national
election holiday we're talking about
restoring rights nationally to
excellence and I think that that has
real value because it offers to the
Democratic primary candidates and then
that whoever the general election
candidate ends up being they can point
to that and say like look the day that I
come into office I'm gonna sign HR 1 the
day that I come into office I'm gonna
sign a bill granting statehood to
Washington DC and you know you and I
know that nothing happens on day 1 it's
a but you know it's something that could
be a month one priority for the next
Democratic administration and you
wouldn't have to waste a bunch of time
running these bills through committees
and debating them and getting the
opposition time to formulate a response
right you just come in you say we have
we already have the legislation I told
you I was gonna sign this Here I am
here's my pen and I'm signing it and I
think it'll give a real momentum to the
early period of that next democratic
presidency which is so crucial and
proving to the voters that you are gonna
pursue the priorities that you told the
voters he would pursue during the
campaign last thing to just touch on
2020 one more time before we wrap up
are there any candidates in particular
that on the basis of what you've
outlined in the book are most closely
adhering to the sort of tactics and
strategy that you recommend yeah I think
there's two candidates that are that
have been pretty aggressive about to
step on the trail so far one is
Elizabeth Warren I
who has endorse DC statehood she's
talked about the filibuster in ways that
are really interesting you know she she
there was this long quote him in the
movie with her where she said you know
we can't just let Republicans violate
these norms and then we come in instead
of we're gonna play by the old rules
right like that that will no longer
apply if I'm president and she didn't
say I'm gonna do XY and Z but but the
implicit threat there what's very real
and then blue digits
who you know I think has was not really
on anybody's radar a couple of months
ago has had a very successful rollout in
which one of the ways he's distinguished
himself from the field is saying yeah I
will entertain the idea of adding
justices to the Supreme Court and while
that's not I think a winning general
election plan and I don't necessarily
think you should run on it per se I do
think communicating to a certain segment
of the Democratic primary electorate
that you are willing to be extremely
aggressive procedurally and exactly the
way the Republicans have been that that
to me is a is a good message in a good
way for somebody who doesn't have much
name recognition nationally to
distinguish himself from the rest of the
field so those are the two that I think
are being most aggressive about it so
far you know I'm happy to see them
saying all these things I hope that they
are paired with a robust progressive
agenda I'm more confident that with with
Warren that I am a Buddha judge because
we hadn't really seen him take positions
on all these policy ideas whereas Warren
has this like incredible policy shop
with a number of really cool ideas not
not stuff from my book but you know ways
of reforming the way that capitalism
works in America that I think are really
interesting so I'm looking forward to
hearing more from both of them as well
as all the other candidates when when
the debates get going
the book is it's time to fight dirty how
Democrats can build a lasting majority
in American politics we've been speaking
with the book's author David Ferris
who's an associate professor of
political science at Roosevelt
University David thanks for coming back
on today oh there's a great time any
time